so this will be the second video on the
series on electron transport chain in
the first video we'll discuss the
overview and the various complexes of
the electron transport chain make sure
to watch that video before watching the
second video on this topic also make
sure to watch the videos and Krebs cycle
glycolysis as well as we talked sedation
before watching this video
so let's try to understand how the
electron transport chain actually works
here is an illustration which depicts
the membrane structure of the
mitochondria as well as the organization
of the various electron gene complexes
compare it to the structure of the
mitochondria we can see that here is the
outer mitochondrial membrane on the
inside we have the inner mitochondrial
membrane which is represented by this
space between the bottom two lines of
the illustration the space between them
is the inter membrane space and a space
inside the mitochondria is the matrix of
the mitochondria in the matrix of the
mitochondria we have the various
biochemical cycles like the Krebs cycle
as well as the bead oxidation of fatty
acids these biochemical cycles generate
reducing occurrence called the NADH and
the fadh2 the electron transport begins
when the NADH donates its electrons to
the first complex in the first complex
the electrons are first received by the
flavin mononucleotide prosthetic group
the FM n then donates the electrons to
the iron sulfur proteins these are redox
reactions in which the iron ions go from
the ferrous state to the ferric state
depending upon when they receive and
when they donate the electrons in the
next step the iron sulfur proteins
donate electrons to coenzyme q q is the
ubiquinol which is a freely permeable
molecule inside the inner mitochondrial
membrane these redox reactions generate
energy which is used to pump four
hydrogen ions from the matrix of the
mitochondria into the intermembrane
space
the coenzyme q then combines with two
hydrogen ions from the matrix of the
mitochondria and gets converted to the
reduced form of ubiquinone now coming to
the second complex which is the
succinate dehydrogenase complex this
complex contains the enzyme succinate
dehydrogenase the succeded dehydrogenase
catalyzes the conversion of succinate to
fumarate in the Krebs cycle
this is oxidation reaction which causes
the generation of fadh2
the fadh2 stay inside the second complex
and donate the electrons to the iron
sulfur complexes of the complex 2
the electrons are then transferred to
the ubiquinone in a similar way as the
electrons are transferred from the first
complex
the ubiquinol is a freely permeable
molecule inside the inner mitochondrial
membrane which is used to transfer
electrons to the third complex in the
third complex the electrons are first
received by the cytochrome C one the
cytochrome C one then transfer the
electrons to iron sulfur proteins which
then donate the electrons to cytochrome
B these are all redox reactions the
electrons are then transferred to the
cytochrome C which is an intermediate
protein used to donate electrons to the
force complex
the redox reactions inside the third
complex cause the bumping of four
hydrogen ions to the intermembrane space
in the next step the cytochrome C under
Nate's the electron to the force complex
in the fourth complex the electrons are
first received by the copper ions which
are of a type the copper ions in donate
electron to the cytochrome a
the cytochrome a then transfers the
electron to copper ions which are of B
type these copper ions then transfer the
electrons to cytochrome a3 the
cytochrome a 3 in the final step donates
the electrons to the final electron
acceptor which is the oxygen the oxygen
combines with two hydrogen ions from the
matrix of the mitochondria and gets
reduced to water these redox reactions
in the fourth complex cause the pumping
of two hydrogen ions to the
intermembrane space all this pumping of
hydrogen ions into the intermembrane
space causes a generation of higher
concentration of hydrogen ions into the
inner membrane space as compared to the
low concentration inside the matrix of
the mitochondria
inner mitochondrial membrane is an
impermeable membrane to ions so hydrogen
ions cannot cross the membrane as such
here comes a role of another enzyme
called the ATP synthase the ATP synthase
is present inside the inner
mitochondrial membrane and it uses the
flow of hydrogen ions from higher
concentration to the lower concentration
to generate energy this energy is used
to phosphorylate adenosine diphosphate
to adenosine triphosphate this is the
basis of generation of energy inside the
body the working of ATP synthase can be
compared to the working of a
hydroelectric power project the water
that is collected behind the dam can be
compared to the hydrogen ions in a
higher concentration in the
intermembrane space the turbines of the
dam can be compared to the enzyme ATP
synthase
when the water flows from a height which
is compared to the flow of hydrogen ions
come higher gradient to the lower Brady
and this causes the spinning of turbines
inside the dam which can be compared to
the functioning of ATP synthase the
power is generated inside the dam which
tend to compare to the adenosine
triphosphate generated to ATP synthase
so this was the mechanism of working of
the electron transport chain
now let's talk about the various energy
calculations for per molecule of glucose
that passes through the biochemical
cycles of glycolysis kreb cycle as well
as the electron transport chain in
glycolysis when glucose is converted to
pyruvate we get a net of two ATP's and
two NADH in the next step when pyruvate
is converted to acetyl co a we again get
two NADH
in the kreb cycle when glucose passes
through one cycle of Krebs cycle it
gives to GTP's which are energy
equivalent to two ATP's we also get 6
nadh + 2 fadh2 all these reducing agents
are then metabolized in the electron
transport chain in the electron
transport chain we metabolize the two
nadh from glucose to pyruvate conversion
also the two NADH we get from the
conversion of pyruvate to acetyl-coa and
the six NADH and the to fadh2 we get
from the Krebs cycle in the electron
transport chain for every four hydrogen
ions that flow through the ATP synthase
one molecule of ATP is generated so when
four hydrogen ions pass through ATP
synthase it is utilized for the
phosphorylation of one molecule of
adenosine diphosphate a one molecule of
NADH which donates its electron to the
electron transport chain causes the
movement of ten hydrogen ions from the
matrix to the intermembrane space these
hydrogen ions then flow back through the
ATP synthase give rise to 2.5 ATP's in a
similar way one fadh2 causes the
movement of six hydrogen ions to the
intermembrane space which when moved
back give rise to 1.5 ATP's
using these values we can calculate that
two NADH from the conversion of glucose
to pyruvate will give five ATP's
similarly conversion of pyruvate to
acetyl co wave will give five ATP's in
the electron transport chain six NADH we
get through the Krebs cycle will give
rise to fifteen ATP's and the to fadh2
of the krebs cycle gave rise to three
ATP's in a total we get twenty ATP's
from the Krebs cycle we get seven ATP's
from the conversion of glucose to
pyruvate in glycolysis and we get five
ATP's from the conversion of pyruvate to
acetyl co a in a total we have thirty
two ATP's per molecule of glucose which
passes through all these biochemical
cycles so this was all about the
electron transport chain and the energy
production
thank you so much for watching this
video I hope you found this video
helpful for all the new visitors make
sure to hit the subscribe
for all